>> In addition to that atlas we have, we also have a very large and very complex
data file. This data file represents how the atlas should be rendered to draw
the entire map. Now this is a pretty complex file because its actually been
generated by an external tool, called tile. Prior to running the game, and
artist would take our atlas data and the tile tool. For grids, we actually read
the exported JSON data into our game, which tells us how to render the images
and the tiles on the screen. Now, in order to actually render our map, we need
to parse the exported data file that we've been given from the tiled editor. The
data the we extract from this will tell us a number of things. First off, what
atlases to load. And secondly, how the layers are organized, given to us by the
artist. For example, you can see that the data layer here actually references
what tiles to render, as well as the height and the name of the layer itself.
We'll need to be able to scrape all this and properly understand how it's laid
out to render our final image.